ми ж всі три десятки державних колорадо
компанії в Україні про свою памелу та
рудничне підставі ти порвані мої
частоти платформою для створи несу
спинного мозку не публічного
акціонерного товару вид-во з встигли цього
радіокомпанія України
долю всіх слухаючи програму українська
вимер у трипурі роман коля до видачі та
директор київського радіо редагувати зал
стане кілька місяців разом із командою
банат з рабів за для пари формату ваня
контент вмивання головному це притвора не
тримаючи блага мова nexus пиляльного ланцюга did
та вид інформаційного обслуговування
владою через досить інформативний тато
царство
за раз у соціумі по ширина думка рахунок і
бабусі на радіо і так скажу тут зі
рахунком на кисть брехун етики та у
старенької бабусі на кухні трісок і ж
бути люди і кіу wing null і за 1
українське радіо та ноги намагаюся від ще
ви
торцевим з нічного світу і ну вилазь і
видос дорожня карта реформи державна
гамова не я публічний активний він цього
райського національного зі стильно і про
радіокомпанія України травня за і витяг
пішому залучити і 2016 руку
dota і фірма і кардинально він на жаль за
роботою ікони та упирі джен їм і
актуальною судовою зміїною в жирі
думається all is добий шоу каїві
вона в районах у регіонах наші монітори
не показувати що на таксі
добра так тонн і фсб anakata не
продовжити pr це месія владу на
екшену їх немає з на cd коди відбуває
все-таки така внутрішня самоцензура
державним про війну сьогодні сама живи
синтетичним рубає не ким ще на
початку реформи було заявлено чотири ти
0 так я буду ланка але з виду знак
нути ідейки передачі
хто самий пік домогтися поліпшення в
вирішив це і рада розум попит
keuco ми піридоксин їм родами на
покурити на увазі помста не знаєш
буде але як сама
Рахунку безо пропонують choose to notice
на шию студію.
успішність реформа українського тіла
породив мій кінець нічну світові за лежить і
ми вигляд фінам
vanya сильно законом йдіть про 0,2 500к
навіть бюджету нарік що правда про проект
бюджету на 2016 рік
нас у спинному кути не перед веж розуму я
живий 2 чим менше заздрість 1 мільярда 600
мільйонів ривай